[MUSIC]
A couple months ago I received a text
message from an unknown number.
Now usually I don't respond to unknown
numbers but this was different.
The text read, hey Miss Edwards,
it's Sade I immediately respond back,
where are you?
How are you?
Are you still in school?
And then I flash back to
a moment about two years ago when
I was working as director of operations
of a charter school in North New Jersey.
Sade was one of my students, and
we formed a very special bond.
But on this particular day Sade
had been kicked out of school for
cursing out the school principal.
Now I had a feeling there
was more to the story.
So I took it upon myself to leave
the school building and go find her, and
find out what really happened.
So I walk out the building and
as soon as I step outside I see
Sade sitting on the steps of the church
next to the school and she's crying.
So I walk over to Sade and I sit down
next to her, ask her what's going on.
I soon find out that
Sade wasn't particularly
angry with the school principal that day.
She just really, really missed her dad.
You see the year before Sade's
father had passed away.
But her family was too poor
to afford a tombstone, so
her father was cremated,
against both his and his family's wishes.
Sade/e was upset that day because on that
day she just wanted a physical place
to remember her father and
she had nothing,so she was upset.
So at this point I look at Sade and
I tell her Sade give me your phone.
I'm going to call your mom,
we'll make sure you get home safe and
don't worry about the principal.
I'll just make sure you get
back to your family right now.
And then Sade looks up at me and
she goes, he took my phone.
I said, who took your phone Sade?
And she said, the man.
I'm like okay, what man Sade?
She said, the man with the gun.
Right before you came he put the gun
in my face and he took my phone.
At this point, I just have to stop.
I look around me, it's broad daylight,
it's lunchtime just like it is now.
I hear laughter in the distance,an
argument down the street,and here we are,
sitting on the steps of a church,
and a young girl morning her father
had just been robbed at gunpoint for
her cell phone.
And, in that moment,
I realized there's no education reform,
there's no large scale theory of change or
impact model, there's no design thinking
white boards or post it notes, no case
study that would have ever prepared me for
how to react in that moment.
So instead Sade leaned on my shoulder and
cried and I tried not to cry.
The next time I turned and looked at Sade,
I felt like I saw the world in her eyes.
The world she was living in seemed so
dark,so unfair,so scary but
the world I saw living in her was
when dominated by her godlike
personal strength and that was then that
I realize a greater truth about life.
We all may live in this world but
we choose how we let the world live in us.
If we fast forward it today,
Sade's mother is a drug addict and
to this day,
I have no idea where in the world Sade is.
Anyone looking at her records would see
her poor grades, her poor behavior,
her lack of attendance rate or
even her dropout rate at this point but
what the records don't show is that I
have seen something divine in that child.
Today, I'm not speaking to you as
the future business leaders, and
entrepreneurs and policymakers,
which I know you all will become one day.
Instead I'm coming to you
humbly under the most
basic common denominator that connects me,
you, Mark Zuckerberg, Beyonce, and
even Sade/g,our humanity.
You see, at the GSB, we talk about
changing the world as if the world is
some vague, distant thing that we will
magically reenter after we graduate.
But the truth about the world
is this: we are it,
the world is now, the world is here.
It is so easy to get caught up in school,
work, politics, and the very visible
differences that divide and separate
everyone sitting in this room today.
But if we want to take,
if we want to change the world
we have to be willing to look beyond
what's visible to the eye in other people.
Now, you may call this seeing God,
or the divine, in someone.
You may call this acknowledging
someone's humanity.
Whatever we call it, we have to choose to
see something greater in ourselves and
other people because in
the absence of something greater
we miss out on the bigger
picture about life.
That life is not about us.
Life is about the value we create and
the legacy we'll leave behind and
if we don't see anything
greater in ourselves or
the people around us, our legacy
will end as soon as our lives end.
But if we take the time to see and
believe in something beyond ourselves and
align our work with a higher cause or
a higher purpose not only will
our lives be much richer,
but the work we do will live forever.
So how do we begin seeing more
in other people and ourselves?
Well, the answer is, we're going to have
to rediscover our sense of wonder and
awe in the world.
Albert Einstein once said he
who can no longer wonder and
stand wrapped in awe is as good as dead,
his eyes are closed.
As a child, it's very natural for us to
wonder and stand in awe of the world.
But as adults, we tend to assume that we
know everything that the world's about.
Wonder is defined as a heightened State of
Consciousness, brought upon by something
so beautiful, something so rare, so
unexpected, something that is a marvel.
It was a wonder for
me, to see the strength in Sade,
as she mourned the passing of her father.
Today, it is a wonder that I'm even
able to talk in front of you all.
And for some of us in the room,
it was a marvel to even get
out of bed this morning.
Wonder has been shown to be one of
the most important emotional foundations
underlying optimum mental health and
not only is it linked to improved health,
but the capacity for experiencing wonder
and awe has been linked to improve
our abilities to build stronger,
more cohesive teams and communities.
So my challenge to you today, go home and
write down one wonder you
saw in someone else today.
One wonder that enriched your
understanding of your world.
I promise if you do this, you'll
experience the world in a much deeper and
richer way than you ever have before.
I have realized that I may never
hear back from Sade again.
I may never have the answers to
the questions that I texted her.
But what I do know is that my life is so
much richer.
Because I took the time
to see the world in her.
What will people say
when they look at you?
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]